j'ai vu qu'en ce moment un site internet
recherche entre 5 à 10 personnes pour
effectuer un jeu un job de rêve où le
travail consiste à tester des maisons de
luxe alors la rémunération pour un
séjour d'une semaine et de 2300 euros
vous testez les maisons de luxe
césarienne dans un truc de ouf
tranquille et vous ouvrez le frigo et
baba bye baby beel d'accord à la cantine
est là le travail consiste à jauger le
style le confort et la pertinence des
sites visités pour faire un rapport de
800 mo minimum
franchement c'est bon ou pas c'est
génial c'est énorme c'est le travail
révèle weekly alors est-ce qui choisit
des gens lambda où il choisit des des
influenceurs ont déjà qu'ils ont la leur
et choisit des jo lauda même des gens de
lambada même des gens qui voyagent globe
quels étaient les boues le job de rêve
que vous rêveriez de faire à vous moi je
le fais déjà ckoi critique littéraire et
il est et reste à dire être payé pour
lire non alors là c'est l'idéal dans ma
vie j'ai tout eu l'occasion d'exercer
ici mais dans l'absolu c'est ça c'est
fou quoi c'était votre rêve
c'est mon rêve être payé pour laisser ce
qui m'arrive est franchement moi même
rêver un moment si on va mettre payer
pour lire au dos mais les mémoires des
prospectus à l'eau
le prospectus de kiloutou ce serait d
autres tester des hôtels dans le monde
entier on vous l'avait déjà fait avec
votre ex
non on sait ce qu'il faisait là ils vont
vous connaissez tous le temps au même
endroit six à monsieur ma belle-mère
quoi et pas des autres
quoique encore est ce à dire que vous
comment est gérée sur ma bête vous
faisiez la mouche et votre belle-mère
pardon tu voudrais d'abord les témoins
du tout le cas mais fait pas l'amour les
nouveaux jamais sous parasols et et
[Applaudissements]
n'ouvre pas son petit patelin joie que
faire le rideau pour aller dans le monde
entier vous avez deux résidents les plus
grands hôtels de vous tester tous vous
donc c'est vraiment votre job rêvé ce
serait génial ah bah écoute et kelly ses
courtiers ce que votre journal ce serait
guide touristique mais dans la mer et
seulement dans la mer mais quand vous
voulez que les gens on entendre chez
rennes avec des des pancartes ils des
pancartes oui c'est un peu sinon d'être
existe ça existe vous partez dans les
antilles en vacances il faut de passe et
vous plonger dans la mer et qui sont
envolées de visiter le les océans à l
écoute et socgen ont peu de police 1
on attaque les dauphins toute la journée
les retiens ça fait pas être les deux
fois qu'il y aura de mes animaux
préférés
c'est vrai le deux fois qu'il animal
préféré d'un camarade de classe de ma
fille bianca clément voilà parce qu'il a
des qualités exceptionnelles malawi les
membres le dos un lead ou gilbert bel en
moi je voudrais être leader de la
patrouille de france les avions là comme
ça tranquille leader de la mecque et je
vous dis la vérité
la vente un avion je veux juste montrer
mais c'est pas comme ça qu'on va vous
êtes chauffeur de car et c'est vous qui
allez jean michel c'est quoi votre job
rêvé baba chasseurs de trésors toujours
que ça sorte de trésor a barrel moi j'ai
été élevé 11 après la guerre enfin en
chine aversion des 112 et quand il était
petit tous les week-ends et aimer poêle
à frire à chercher des choses comme ça
dans mes carnets moi aussi et moi je
vous dis à chaque fois même que j'arrive
à zéro les émissions je casse tout les
murs pour savoir s'il ya des trésors
derrière son nom mais non j'ai pas con
con mais au moins de nom mais c'est vrai
les étapes au mur comme ça que tu es
bien sûr je fais comme ça je suis à ma
mère maman il ya un trésor médias
arrêtent et caudry bien manger les
boulettes alors moi éventuellement
c'était veto mais j'ai trouvé un truc
depuis ce matin qui me convient mieux
c'est sauver des armes par sauver des
arbres mais oui partout on voulait
répéter
attendez j'ai découvert mon héros c'est
le mec qui s'enchaînent aux armes pour
éviter qu'on les coupe pro vous allez
devoir essayer d'établir un contact afin
d'en faire ce qu'il s'en tienne aux
arbres et vous êtes à côté de lui je
pense que même l'armée va sauver des
recherches on peut pas le faire trop
comment
et sinon communes comme eric je suis
payé à regarder la télévision
globalement et moi c'était mon rêve est
un petit devant notre télé donc quelque
part c'est bah oui on embrasse collègues
d'air t elle d'ailleurs ça se passe bien
rtl trespass vous sera limité dans
l'émission l'année prochaine ben
normalement oui c'est ainsi dit donc là
bas ça fait 25 ans 25 ans tous les
matins tous les matins c'est beau elle
se réveille tous les matins du monde est
content ou pas franchement c'est bon
donald trois jours tu faisais de courage
j'adore ça mais c'est vrai quoi vous
adorez j'adore ça puis ça vous permet de
ne pas dormir toute la nuit avec votre
mari je la connais un petit peu jamais à
vous ou à la non non pas du tout
[Applaudissements]
et c'est pas top gun thallion ouais
ouais là series c'est bien des top guns
d'ailleurs quoi j'ai un petit peu des
top guns marketing
on a vu ce que ça donnait 1 il a divorcé
deux mois après c'était pour sida oui
oui c'était bien n'hésitez pas marié
aussi ont tout en blanc en officier et
gentleman skoda moi si je devais changer
complètement de vie je voudrais vendre
des fromages
non mais j'adore j'adore ça mais que
valent les champs moi tu des plateaux
avec la pâte molle à pâte dure ou
chagnaud élèves cargo là je suis dans le
paysage attrait les malades étaient
molles c'est comme ça qu'on appelle t il
[Applaudissements]
ici un dossier se bat bien mais je ne
sais pas si vous avez vu ça vous remet
sur l'année c'est un trio ils l'ont mais
pas une dent alors oui j'adore je trouve
que le fromage c'est très sain
les odeurs je défendrai sur les marchés
ouais tu achètes direct c'est vrai j'ai
un grand plateau comme ça tout ça oui
c'est sympa vrai c'est bon moi je moi
j'adore le sainte albret le roquefort
albanie des ailes d'ange moi j'avais
d'autres comme j'aime pas les clés les
fromages avec des trucs verts j'aime les
fromages qui sont tranquilles mode son
bo3 préférez quoi le caprice des dieux
et blanche on dirait muc72
[Applaudissements]
alors il ya un truc avec le baby pas
avec le caprice des dieux et jaune à
ceux qui nous regardent est fière c'est
que j'adore les extrémités parce
qu'elles sont très moelleuse les frais
au milieu si vous avez ou pas il ya des
trucs bien toujours un tabou bah ouais
c'est plus dur on dirait qu'à du chèvre
et donc je vous mets l'extrémité du
caprice des dieux et gestes ou le milieu
que sur les gens insupportable qui font
ça parce que moi je suis un colloque
avec ma meilleure amie et quand je fais
les courses
j'arrive le soir et j'ai les deux
extrémités qui sont coupées la voilà je
trouve ça insupportable
oui mais moi et c'est avec cela et c'est
ce que fait il ya aussi alors il vaut
mieux préférer mais je suis là frère par
contre sur la tête de ma mère un à
chaque fois que tu la mets la maison car
tout le frigidaire en direct à ton père
t'a enlevé ses chaussures
le saint père
il est bonne et moi je mange plus j'ai
arrêté avant j'étais avant je me faisais
même des soirées s'intégrer mais sur la
tête de ma mère on habitait 4,16 copains
et on mangeait connu certains vrais et
chacun met son ca talent pris fin et
après ordino chaussures on était
tranquille au moins c'était de regarder
c'est vrai sur ma vie c'est vrai et vous
vous aimez
oui mais le fromage qui pue est pas le
fromage à l'elysée comme ça comme ça
alors que j'adore c'est le contest c'est
génial mais c'est cher le comté compte
qu'on est les plus pour les fromages
qu'elle soit toujours bonne mais oui
acer et le baby beel alléchant mais
comme je vous ai dit la dernière fois le
meilleur c'est quand même le manuel
quand tu fais la boule rouge comme
sanitaires et tu fais un qui fait tu vas
voir ta parole tu dis maman regarde la
belle boule que j'ai fait
combien de fois je les fais ça il ma
mère était content même prenez pour un
artiste de l'année c'est vrai non mais
tu devrais vous avez jamais été les
boules comme sa route comme si qu'elle
kiffe mon frère et j'en avais plein
comme ça moi je fais une collection de
boules rouges
je te jure mais et après qu'il en était
des strepsils pas par celui là moi je
veux radiata par job de rêve la détester
les vies de la baïonnette
j'aurais bien voulu dans job de rêve
être consultant foot j'adore le foot
d'en bas d'en je le fais j'ai la chance
de faire mes jeux je suis en sus d'un
pote vous fait un petit mozart vous êtes
consultant touffe
non mais aller au stade gratuitement
pour regarder des matches c'est un job
de rêve ont fait mal mais c'est un petit
peu ce que vous mine de rien vous n'êtes
pas suite à la croche vous n'êtes pas
loin de zéro cyril et moi vous le savez
il est bon ça vous le savez c'est quoi
joueur de tennis a bien sûr tu es joueur
de tennis voilà nadal djoko federer
voilà un jour je me suis posé une
question alors je la pose aux
téléspectateurs est-ce que je
préfèrerais être federer maintenant vous
bien genre un jeune joueur qui démarre
toujours parlé d'une petite fille parce
qu'à pas encore pu gagner dont federer
s'est alors faire et bas march
d'affaires est city la clac et oui mais
c'est fini